It's my husband's birthday in a couple days,
and I always have the hardest time
trying to figure out what to get the man
for his birthday.
I wanted to do something a little bit different this year,
and I've been hearing a lot of good things about the website moonpick.
So me and the boys decided to make our own custom cards for dad,
and they came in the mail today.
I did it all on my phone,
and they had a bunch of templates you could choose from,
and then you can customize it however you want.
There's, like, a million different ways you can do it.
So this is the one that I made to be sweet.
It has all our pictures.
These were, like,
my favorite moments from the entire time that I've known him.
And this card is from my kids.
They picked out the colors,
they picked out the design and everything,
and they had a lot of fun,
and they're gonna be so excited to give it to their dad.
Like I said, we literally made these cards
on my phone while we were sitting on the couch,
and they got shipped out right away.
So easy. They're super affordable and great quality.